es wird crazy es geht los ich habe
selber ich bin sehr Hype ja jetzt geht's
los ich bin jetzt wirklich weg ich habe
Gefühle die kannte ich noch überhaupt
gar nicht es ist krass es ist krank
bevor es dazu gekommen ist dass die
seven vs world Staffel 2 Teilnehmer
wirklich in Südamerika angekommen sind
ist unheimlich viel passiert es mussten
unvorhersehbare Probleme gelöst werden
es kam zu Verletzungen im Team und es
musste eine Menge organisiert und
vorbereitet werden um euch hier aber die
ersten Momente der Teilnehmer so
ungefiltert wie möglich vor Staffelstart
am Samstag zeigen zu können haben wir
uns entschieden dieses Video jetzt schon
zu veröffentlichen alles was bis zu
diesem Punkt und darüber hinaus passiert
ist erfahrt ihr in den nächsten Folgen
von sevenvers Wild behind the scenes
[Musik]
alles gut
wenn wir nicht euer euer Backstage
Reporter vorher macht dass er heilfroh
ist hier falls irgendwas schlimmer ist
als erstes je gedacht hat dann wäre
alles okay
ready wenn mir was passiert da kriegen
die Herren von wandermut eine Klage aber
das ist Schallert
die sind wirklich da wir sind da alle
Leute die gesagt haben aber vergiss es
wir sind angetreten und anzutreten
bedeutet schon echt viel wir haben
telefoniert Nächte lang wir haben Eier
gezeigt Sascha auch aber so ist morgen
oder nicht wir sterben Krokodile und wir
sind da wir haben es gemacht
ob sie gute Entscheidung war wissen wir
jetzt noch selbst nicht noch nicht aber
das wird sich zeigen
[Musik]
die Meter ist halt was so gut
live in Panama City peoples
jetzt kommst du mit deinem Spanisch
kommst okay
[Musik]
und ich habe es mit meinem Spanisch
hinbekommen
zimmerkarten für alle und dann macht
euch aber ein bisschen frisch und um 7
Uhr treffen wir uns wieder hier unten in
der Lobby und dann Abfahrt was Abfahrt
wir können hier was essen oder Anna
geileren Location wo ja noch so ein
bisschen Skyline von Panama machen
[Musik]
ein Tag voll mit Briefings
wichtig wie fast alles dazu dass sie
nicht kapiert
ist kein Spaß wenn er nicht aufpassen
selber
Schuldner
Paradise running
experience with Training
angefangen mit Tomek Elroy der als
survival und insbesondere Experte der
Region wichtige Einzelheiten über die
Insel erzählt hat was bringt dich um was
kannst du essen und vor allem aber was
besser nicht
die Teilnehmer erwartet eine bunte
Vielfalt an Tieren Pflanzen und äußerer
Umstände die wirklich gefährlich sein
können der umgangssprachlich
todesapfelbaum genannte maschinellbaum
beispielsweise trägt Früchte die kaum
von normalen Äpfeln zu unterscheiden
sind bei Verzehr allerdings zum Tod
führen können für sein Gift gibt es bis
heute kein Gegenmittel okay dann bitte
einmal alle Aufstehen das ganze jetzt
unterschreiben
Alter ist schon anders als gedacht ne
und jetzt alle unterschreiben was wir
gerade gehört habt dann wenn ihr stirbt
es ist alles wir sind hier abgesagt
worden das ist ganz anders als mit
Gedanken
die größten der Welt die größten
Krokodile also die Welt der größte
Fehler der Welt und ich sag dir ein
Geheimnis das Wichtige ist glaube ich
2008 gemacht auch bei meiner ersten
Fernseh schauen ne der Vertrag kommt 32
Seiten es heißt und den hat auch das
Profil unterschrieben Stift und dann
auch nicht mehr lesen es bringt nichts
ist alles neu Stachelrochen die überall
flächendeckend auf dem Boden sind die
dir sofort das Bein reinhacken das ist
ja ganz neu wo soll ich mich bewegen
sehr krank Krokodile sehr große ja
ja
geht nicht anders aber kein Problem
Alltag länger als Fritz Willenskraft
wir haben einmal Thorsten die Erste
Hilfe Ausbilder für Outdoor und unseren
praxisnah und die werden euch jetzt ein
bisschen was erklären eine Grundregel
bei der Ersten Hilfe und das ist
Prävention ist King also alles das was
uns nicht passiert ist eine wunderbare
Sache die Regel könnte man auch
übersetzen in don't do you stupid shit
wenn ich mit einer Machete rumwirble
sowie Tom das gesagt hat sollte ich
zusehen wo mein Bein ist wenn ich auf
einer Klippe stehe die 10 m hoch ist und
wir denke das wäre ein geiles Bild für
die Kamera denke ich vielleicht noch mal
drüber nach bevor ich runter springe
also es gibt verschiedene Dinge in
diesem Leben die einfach schneller töten
als andere und meine erste Frage wäre
jetzt an euch was könnt ihr euch
vorstellen was macht schnell
totverlust viel Blutverlust ganz genau
so wie starten wir eine kritische
Blutung als allererstes
wir nehmen die Hand wir drücken drauf
und wir lassen erstmal nicht mehr los
Thorsten und Islam aus dem medical team
haben den Leuten dann gezeigt wie sie
sich in Notsituationen selber verarzten
können von kleinen Verletzungen
Reizungen und Unwohlsein bis hin zu
Kopfverletzungen und extremen Blutungen
für die beispielsweise die Anwendung von
turnities wichtig sein kann und wirklich
jede Sekunde Zeit und merkst du bist
besser ist du wahnsinnig das kannst du
doch einer drin was kannst du und in dem
Moment
und dann den Clip hier drüber
dieses Jahr gibt es zum ersten Mal zwei
Medikits für ihn eins das bei Öffnungen
wie letztes Jahr zu Punkt Abzug führt
und eins dass das sofortige Ausscheiden
zufolge hat ist dieses Medikit geöffnet
hat der Teilnehmer aber vermutlich eh
größere Probleme als die Wertung denn
dieses Kit ist so doofes klingt nur
dafür da den verletzten etwas länger am
Leben zu halten bis die Rettungskräfte
eintreffen das Team und auch die
Teilnehmer sind dieses Jahr deutlich
besser ausgestattet um wirklich für jede
Situation vorbereitet zu sein dazu aber
sehr ausführlich in den nächsten Folgen
mehr Peddy hat danach die Basics der
Kommunikation und Rettungswege erklärt
wann sendet man einen Code green was im
Prinzip ein todmann-system ist damit die
zentrale weiß dass alles gut ist wann
ein kordillo der eine Abholung des
Teilnehmers einleitet ohne das
lebensgefahr besteht und wann ein
correkt was so viel heißt wie der
Teilnehmer ist in akuter
lebensbedrohlicher Situation und muss
schnellstmöglich mit allen verfügbaren
Ressourcen aus der Situation gerettet
werden zum Schluss hat Max noch eine
ausführliche Anleitung zur Nutzung der
gopros SD-Karten und allgemein des
Technik cases gegeben die Teilnehmer
müssen dafür Sorge tragen dass immer
alle Akkus geladen sind nichts verloren
geht und sie natürlich alles bestmöglich
in Eigenregie festhalten damit es
überhaupt Material gibt dass ihr am Ende
zu Gesicht bekommt all diese Dinge
mussten den Teilnehmern zwingend mit an
die Hand gegeben werden damit sie nicht
ernsthaft zu Schaden kommen wir haben
natürlich niemandem Tipps gegeben
sondern dem ein oder anderen
wahrscheinlich nur noch mehr Druck
gemacht was aber völlig normal ist wenn
man 8 Stunden darüber spricht was alles
schief gehen kann
was mache ich sehr gut das allererste
wir packen drauf auf die Blüte
und keine Angst nur weil ihr jetzt noch
nicht wisst wird Tom Thorsten Islam oder
Paddy sind all diese Personen und alle
ihre Aufgabenbereiche werden in den
nächsten Folgen hier im behind the
scenes noch erklärt und gezeigt also
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
damit ihr das nicht verpasst
sofort
[Musik]
Rücken runter komm
runter
[Musik]
was bist du dran
Du bist derjenige super machst du
super super
[Musik]
weil die Teilnehmer ja komplett alleine
ausgesetzt werden müssen wir uns bevor
sie ausgesetzt werden um alles kümmern
was wir an Aufnahmen von ihm brauchen
also Hero schauts Fotos und so ziemlich
alles was dazugehört deswegen haben sich
alle schon eine Schale geschmissen in
ihre wirklichen survival Outfits und wir
drehen und fotografieren sie jetzt
wieder auch hier ist mal wieder richtig
geil zu sehen das ganze ist halt von uns
einfach Freestyle produziert das ist
keine riesen Produktion hier Turnen
nicht 50 Leute rum das ganze Licht was
kommt ist nicht aus irgendwelchen LEDs
die aufwendig aufgebaut wurden wir
arbeiten mit den Mitteln die wir haben
es ist mega geil und es kommt alles
quasi aus der Hand von einem winzigen
Team es ist richtig richtig geil
[Musik]
um wirklich vergleichen zu können was
die sieben Tage körperlich mit den
Teilnehmern machen mussten sie sich nach
Briefings und Shooting noch einer
kleinen Untersuchung unterziehen
gemessen wurde Gewicht Körperfett und
Wasseranteil zumindest wurde es versucht
alles klinisch alles weiß alles wirklich
der ist infiziert okay mein lieber ich
kann dir nur sagen vom Gefühl her letzte
mal wiegen 104 Kilo jetzt hatte ich aber
heute schon Durchfall vier fünf mal
Schuhe ausziehen genau und Hose aus und
T-Shirt raus gut dann einfach drauf
stellen und dann wissen wir nach also
die Kilogramms und dann die Zahlen davor
was ist denn jetzt los
unangenehm man kann die Situation jetzt
auch nicht sein oder vier Männer in
einem Raum einer nackt error
das gibt's doch nicht
bleiben bleiben error
komm
lass wirklich
Müll stellen
also die einzig wirklich verlässlicher
Angabe sind die Kilos aber ich will
gerne wissen auch wie viel Fett habe ich
wirklich das kann damit sein dass das
Geld spinnt das war
wie mein Körper Fett ist
30,4 was kommt danach 42,3
7,1
3298 alright gut
ich hoffe ihr seid alle
Sattel 11 Uhr handyabgabe bedeutet macht
aber dazu kurz verabschiedet euch was
auch immer machen möchtet 11 Uhr hier
handyabgabe und danach gehen wir
schlafen
schatz ich liebe dich sehr
[Musik]
überleben und wenn nicht Transport
erreichen
[Musik]
das wird alles top das wird alles
funktionieren mach dir keine Sorgen ich
mache so lange wie es geht und wenn
nicht mehr geht dann drücke ich ja viel
Liebe
und jetzt nicht
heul jetzt nicht
brauchst nicht voll
das Handy ist so eine der letzte der
letzte irgendwie das letzte Teil so
Zivilisation komm jetzt weg oder
[Musik]
ich war gerade ein Mensch ich mache aus
warte ich mach aus tschüss Schatz jetzt
steht jemand von meinem Zimmer ich muss
Handy abgeben Ciao baby ich liebe dich
sehr liebe liebe wir sehen uns schon
bald
mein Held ja Bärchen wir schaffen das
ich bin immer bei dir meint ich mache
Handy jetzt aus Zeit keine Ahnung ich
kenne das Leben nicht mehr seit in den
90er Jahren als ich mein erstes Nokia
510 hatte gab es keine Zeit in der ich
kein Handy hatte
[Musik]
passiert
Handy abgegeben scheiß auf echt scheiße
auf Social Media alles egal aber da
Kontakt zu Familie Freunde Paulina
einfach
krass zweite Bett News KFA von 34%.
jetzt ins Bett gehen wir wissen nicht
was passiert morgen früh einfach
irgendwann raus raus raus
ich mache einfach morgen um die Zeit
draußen mit der Nacht heißt die Viecher
auf geht's
no fucking irgendwas besser
gibt's
[Musik]
scheiße
und nach der handyabgabe hieß es dann
für alle Teilnehmer ein letztes Mal im
eigenen Zimmer im warmen Bett schlafen
naja nicht für alle Teilnehmer otto
hatte andere Pläne gibt nur mein Video
ich weiß nicht wie viel Uhr haben weil
die Wecker
8:27 Uhr
das kann nicht stimmen weil es einfach
noch mit dem tief in der Nacht ist
und ja unfassbare Schmerzen im Rücken in
dem
Oberschenkel und Arsch haben dann geh ja
probiere ich das jetzt im Haus zu
arbeiten mit im Gym also denkbar
beschissenste Zeitpunkt für solche
Schmerzen muss ich sagen naja aber was
erfreuliches wenn ich meckern hier ich
hatte ja gestern was schönes vorbereitet
falls wir nachts geweckt werden
ich mag es nur gesagt ja macht kommt
gern rein aber ihr solltet für eure
Sicherheit langsam reinkommen
ja ich weiß nicht was du erkennen kann
aber so
eine kleine Falle das klappert dann laut
wenn die reinkommen so ich gehe mal ein
bisschen austrainieren das Zeug gehen
tut tatsächlich besser muss man sagen
Übungen haben auch einwegs gepasst aber
ich weiß gar nicht wie das so sagen soll
ich mir sicher der emotionalste Mensch
aber ich mache mir
hier geht es aber nicht so gut zu wissen
mit so Schmerzen hier reinzugehen und
eventuell die nicht die Show zu versauen
klar wahrscheinlich wäre es gut für
Story wenn Auto am ersten Tag rausfällt
also habe ich mir das selber nicht
vorgestellt ne also
das klingt fühle ich mich gerade nicht
ready an der Insel jetzt teilzunehmen
ohne rezept gesehen haben 4 Uhr
irgendwas
passt
und die Emma stehen eine Stunde diese
Schmerzen unten hat dann habe dann geht
es und mir einfach hin und hergerissen
gerade
also ernsthaft macht das so Sinn oder
macht das keinen Sinn mehr Ehrgeiz sagt
natürlich Auto auf jeden Fall scheißegal
wie Schmerzen sind scheißegal was ist 7
Tage kommen immer durch
und auf der anderen Seite denkt man sich
Gesundheit geht irgendwie vor aber da
denke ich mir was kann schon passieren
leider noch
wir
naja da sieht es aushalten
guten Morgen
gleich die Kamera
in 15 Minuten unten
15 Minuten nicht trödeln
sieht gut aus okay
nicht drücken
guten Morgen Ich bin ready ready machen
15 Minuten unten all deinen scheiß hier
rein alles was du sonst nicht brauchst
schon Dschungel Uniform an nee dann nur
ein T-Shirt dann Dschungel von
ja natürlich vom anziehen deine anderen
Sachen da reinpacken ja
gut bis gleich
guten Morgen
angemalt so wie ihr hier steht warum 2
Uhr noch im Fitnessstudio er dreht den
Spieß um er sucht die Organisator
15 Minuten unten ich habe gerade meine
20 Minuten Achtsamkeitsübung gemacht das
passt mir sehr gut
[Musik]
15 Minuten komplett Montur
zurück alles andere scheißegal
Punkt
10.000€
bis Ende durchgehalten haben es ist
nichts schlimmes wenn beide bis zum Ende
durchhalten ist nichts ansonsten seid
ihr der das erste herausfinden und
andere 10.000
[Musik]
machen wir alles außer Krankheit alles
aus der Gleichung
10.000 Euro
wenn die Sonne untergeht schreie ich
nach dir ich schreibe dir
[Musik]
das ist es das alle Kandidaten in einem
Auto Leute wir sind die Gruppe ist euch
das klar hey wir halten alle durch bis
zum Ende machen wir schaffen das alles
weißt du was ich meine das wird und dann
sehen wir uns wieder nächste Woche und
wir werden uns so viel erzählen wir
sehen unsere liebsten wieder die sind
einfach da wir machen das wir machen das
was soll passieren
ihr müsst eins ihr müsst nur eins
überlegen ey es gibt so viele die kein
Dach über dem Kopf haben die Leben das
jeden Tag vielleicht nicht bei wilden
Tieren aber irgendwo das kann man machen
legt euch in den Dreck mach die Augen ja
was genau 7 Tage vergeben
[Musik]
warte warte
was ist denn das oh nee Alter